recently one of the customers gave us a
really nice feedback she said that
we might not meet the people that we are
meant to date
uh through the app but we might meet a
new people that can
help us or introduce us to our potential
date
so that that makes a lot of points so if
you are
maybe not meeting someone right away but
you're meeting someone new in the place
and they have a group of friends
um that they bring up next time you are
might end up meeting someone welcome to
20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with
c-tech
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
going to talk about dating apps and
we're going to be meeting sabina iman
the founder of blink
sabina is a strategist with 11 years of
marketing and sales experience and a
master's degree in business
administration
focusing on tech and entrepreneurship
her previous experience includes working
at omnicom group
with large companies such as visa
mcdonald's and wrigley
after completing her mba sabino was
consulting b2b tech startups
recently she founded her own company
that is aimed to change online dating
habits and create a new dating
experience for women
sabina iman thank you for joining me for
20 minute leaders
all the way from barcelona spain how are
you doing
i'm doing great michael thank you for
having me
thank you for taking the time to join me
and we're going to talk about the dating
world we're going to talk about online
dating and blink
and and what you're doing there
launching in barcelona
you moved there from madrid originally
from azerbaijan
and so i'm excited to before getting
into the dating space
tell me a little bit about your own
journey how you ended up in in spain
from azerbaijan
and how you ended up in the dating space
okay so that's uh that's a good question
um
when i i was working in azerbaijan for
um omnicom media group for
more than 10 years in marketing space
and i really loved my job that was
something that i was excited about
because it's a super creative and
dynamic working
advertising agency requires you to
constantly like
think of out of the box ideas and
but at some point i realized that i'm
fascinated by what's going on in tech
world and that was the time when i just
started to
see uber coming up airbnb amazon
and like all these tech gents uh popping
up in news with their amazing products
and
um and that that was something far from
where
i was because the country is super young
and
um the technology is still uh
in the face of development so uh
something like a startup or technology
products is relevantly new for the
country so
um that's that's why it was something
that is like was very far
from where i was but it was super
inspiring and
um and i just wanted to be the part of
it so i thought okay i need
some kind of transition tool that can
help me to get there
and i came up with an idea of
to do my mba at ie business school in
madrid
because i is super well known for
innovation and entrepreneurship so i had
this
um craving for creating some product
and uh being the part of that ecosystem
but i just didn't know how so i knew
that i wasn't ready for it but i had
like some ideas
so i decided that i need to gain some
skills that can help me
to narrow that gap and maybe out of that
i can i can
be the part or join join that part of
the of the world
so um i moved to spain and although i
had a kid
and she was just three i still and
yeah that that was the hell of the
journey i
still managed to move to spain do
one one year of intense mba course with
her
in madrid and
graduate and by the time when i
graduated i took
an internship opportunity in one company
that was consulting startups
in madrid and that was my first
experience when i actually
started to to really work with the tech
companies and that was like more of b2b
tech solutions um products that were
meant for banks insurance companies and
so on
but before that i i started to be in
engaged in tech lab in ie and
i developed um a project
with oracle that was uh basically the
platform
to share mobile data so it was the idea
of tokenizing mobile data and
making it more affordable for people so
that everyone can exchange it
and there is no situation when you have
uh on one hand people with unlimited
data and on other hand people who are
like
uh don't have enough data until the end
of it interesting
um yeah that was a really uh
three weeks of intense work um but we
we got um the best blockchain use case
for the telecom
industry so the hard work paid off
and that's when i realized that okay
this is something i'm super excited
about i want to create
products or be the part of that
ecosystem work with startups somehow
uh learn because uh it's a completely
different experience from the corporate
world or working with a well-established
companies uh you have to be super
resourceful and
you have to be super creative and the
speed and that's what
that's what excites me a lot
amazing very very cool now before we
we dive deep into your current startup
give me your your perspective
on the dating world on in the online
sphere so what is happening today in the
in the online dating ecosystem we're
seeing a lot of new players coming in
bumble i believe just went public right
and so what's happening
around the world so uh
yeah overall the dating ecosystem is
super intense so when you are saying to
someone that you are developing a dating
app
uh you most probably uh will hear
that it's uh another dating app
is popping up in the app store because
if you go to the app store you are able
to see like there are
really a lot of products however i think
um
when you look at the dating space we
have big players like tinder bumble
okcupid
hinge now grinder is becoming also
popular
and what we see is that mostly dating
apps are super segmented
and they try to cover the niches except
of
tinder i would say which is more general
a general dating app
bumble is positioning itself as a dating
app for women because
they give their power for a woman to
make the first move
and then for example grinder and hinge
is is hinge is more general as well but
they are also claiming to be able
to be the app that helps to match the
people by the interest
and meant to be deleted and grinder is
the app
for gay communities so
what we see here is that all the apps
that are popping up after tinder and
bumble that try to really cover some
some specific niches um but it's really
hard to get
or to break this uh through these
markets because the clutter is
super intense so you have to to be
a super unique and you have to have a
very unique story to tell to the
customer so why
why they should they should go from the
dating apps that they have been using
for such a long time
and to and switch and try new dating app
um so from one side um
the competition is tight from the other
side there is a huge pain points that
people experience with the existing
dating apps and that's where the
opportunity
lays and especially for women that's
what's something that i have personally
experienced
because i've been living in madrid and
dating apps were something that i have
been using
to meet someone who speaks english
because my my spanish was
super bad and this was the way to filter
out who i can communicate with
um and then i started to use dating apps
i realized that
they do require you to be super
dedicated
and to spend a lot of time on the apps
in order to
really meet the person face to face so
you have to go through
a lot of swipes a lot of matches talk to
different peoples
at the end um to have a chance to really
meet someone
because the choice is so big that people
are just like
uh they don't know how to make the right
choice
when when we have a lot of choices
usually we are like
procrastinating to make a decision and
we think that everything that comes next
will be the best one
right um so so that's how i decided that
there is an opportunity on the market
and um
especially after doing some research and
finding out that most of
the apps have 70 men and 30 women on
them
um which is a huge gap in terms of uh
gender representation on the dating apps
i decided that there is a huge
opportunity to create something that
would be super valuable and interesting
for women
and it's not about a new product but
more about the
experience that the product can give so
completely changing
the way people use online dating apps
and
change the behavior and make
improvements
and in the whole experience of
you know dating and bringing two worlds
together
let's say physical with digital that's
how the
blink was born and the main idea here is
to help people use dating app in order
to be able to get face to face faster
and so you know more tangibly
you know how does blink actually work in
the physical space and you
you moved to barcelona you mentioned to
me before we started in order to launch
the app and you mentioned that the
barcelona
ecosystem is the is a perfect place for
this tell me a little bit about what
what blink actually does and then why
why did you choose barcelona as the
launching spot
sure so blink is the app that works only
when you are
present in some venue and you are able
to match with people
who are present at the venue at the same
moment so
the app doesn't work when you're at home
so there is no
couch swiping mode i i call it there is
no
couch trauma happening behind the scenes
everything is happening in public space
so right now we are active with
restaurants
bars and coffee shops but of course in
the plan we plan to
activate other spaces such as workspaces
gyms and
airports where people actually can meet
within one space
so the idea here is that you go out
somewhere with your friends even
if you're or by yourself you are in the
new city
you want to discover great places um you
can get on the app and you can see
who who is where basically you see the
number of places on the map and you are
able to see how many people
are at the places in the live mode you
can see their small profile pictures
and once you are there you check in you
are able to match with them
in a live mode and you can instantly
decide
okay um i like the vibe you text for a
few minutes
and then you can just offer them to meet
instantly
you go face to face you validate you
understand if there is a connection or
not and from there you can take it
further and decide okay i wanna
i wanna have a date with this person i
wanna go for a coffee
another time or maybe like um just you
know just be friends or
or this is just a way to meet new people
as well um and
and the reason why we chose barcelona
because it's a perfect city
where there are a lot of young people
coming there to study
to work and they are mostly single
they just it's a city that constantly
moves the people around so well people
are not really rooted and
this way there is a huge opportunity
that they can um
start meeting new people in instantly
and
kind of like close the gap of loneliness
when they're uh just arrived to the new
city
very very cool and so as you're
launching in barcelona tell me a little
bit about the actual launch the strategy
how you as the entrepreneur came
thinking through the launch
launching of a dating app you know it's
a marketplace you need to have you know
people
you know if i'm coming into a restaurant
now i need to have more people that are
on the app so that i get a good value
right
exactly so um the idea here is um
because we are putting uh restaurants on
the app
the idea here is the part of the lunch
lunch strategy is to partner with the
with the restaurants
and use them as our marketing platforms
so
because these these restaurants have a
huge audience
of people in their subscribers or
instagram followers
so the idea here is uh to partner with
them
to enable us to cover as many people as
possible without
us overspending on marketing um or doing
like a huge
campaigns by ourselves because this is
already the community that they have
built
and most people already go to the places
so all they need is a bit of push or a
new reason
why they should go out uh more
and when we pla when we plan to roll out
one as i said one of the strategies is
to
build awareness through the partners and
through their customers
by advertising through their instagram
pages by branding
the physical space inside of the
restaurant so anyone who comes there
will be able to scan
and download the app and start to check
in and be visible to people
who are around this is something that
we have planned out as the part of the
rollout strategy
and um as the in order to promote
this whole check-in and and built like a
habit of checking in in different places
so that the usability of the app is high
we plan to um to have like a big lunch
party
where we will invite the people with the
most number of chickens or who went out
like
during the three weeks after the lunch
the most and have collected the more
than 15 chickens
so they will get access to the private
lunch party with like
around 80 100 people on the terrace
that's something that we are looking
forward to
that's very very cool and what what are
some of the some of the matrix that you
will
look at as you launch and as you try to
determine whether you've
you're you've found product market fit
or whether you're you're on the right
track what are the things you're going
to be looking for
as the entrepreneur um so i will
definitely look at them
of course like first initial things
would be the app signups
so how many people are actually signed
up for the app the second
important metric would be how many
people checked in in the venues
and kind of expose themselves to be open
to match and and meet with another
people
that will be like the second key point
and the third key point would be how
many actual matches we had
inside of the venue so how many people
are actually
uh finding what they're looking for and
experiencing what we want to build here
um and it's not just that you know
they're
out of curiosity going somewhere but
then they're like putting the app
in their pockets and getting a drink and
then leaving the
place without like anything happening
further
because that uh that's something that we
understand might be as a risk
um because people get curious but then
when it comes to
to the point when you have to take an
action or an effort
um it can be like a back off so i
believe that this metric would be very
important for us how many actual matches
happen
and the fourth most important is how
many people sent the invitation to meet
because we have this feature
integrated in in our app you can send
the invitation
to meet and um that will be like a
determining point
for us to understand that these are
these people had actually
decided to meet face to face and this is
like the end
the end goal and it doesn't matter if
they decide to date or not to date after
because recently one of the customers
gave us a
really nice feedback she said that we
might not meet the people that we are
meant
to date uh through the app but we might
meet a new people that can help us
or introduce us to our potential date so
that that makes a lot of points so if
you are maybe
not meeting someone right away but
you're meeting someone new
in the place and they have a group of
friends um
that they bring up next time you are
might end up
meeting someone and for us the idea is
we want
to avoid this cliche of like keeping
people engaged just in sake of uh
you know having their high engagement
rate and because that's what makes uh
the whole experience with the apps
miserable for women
no that makes a lot a lot of sense and
you know one of the things that i'm
really curious about constantly is this
idea of how do we as entrepreneurs you
know keep ourselves in check and how do
we
know to ask the right questions and how
do we know to measure exactly what's
happening and whether we're on the right
track or not and
and it sounds like that's type of the
rigorous thinking that that you're a
part of right now
and and i'm excited to see what happens
with the launch and the feedback from
from the customers
and and it just sounds amazing and i do
have a few more questions about you
sure not about blink and not about
dating and i want to go back
to your childhood i believe in
azerbaijan
yes and tell me tell me a little bit
about you know
what fascinated as a kid and what
perhaps what was your favorite subject
um at school i would say that i loved
literature and history a lot
so i was the fan of like uh
um how to say i think that's called like
uh
human sciences or humanity
so anything that is related to um to
that fascinated me a lot because it
helped me to understand people and i
think
at um at core of anything that you do
understanding people and where they come
from and what's happening on the
background
is something that either can like
really it's it's it's the game changer
so yeah
if you manage to kind of be that person
who gets
uh the sense or understanding of what's
going on in the people's head and
and hearts it's just easier and you can
go through any situations in life
but uh when not having that emotional
intelligence that's when
i think things are getting really tough
so i think literature is something that
fascinated me a lot because it helped to
kind of like
um for me i always call it a surgery of
the human soul
you know some some writers manage to
open up
it in such a way that you are able to
look inside
and then anything that comes from
outside any external behavior you can
explain
easier to yourself and with a less
judgment because you understand that and
i think nothing can
give you those skills or understanding
or sense as as much as
reading like literature um definitely
and so i was fascinated by this a lot
and also
history i was a fan of like ancient
greek and egyptian histories i was like
collecting
uh different articles i had this theory
of like this civilization
being way more advanced than what we
have uh think about
them at at some point and the pyramids
that they have built
the culture and the science uh
discoveries that they have made that was
something that
super fascinating for me um so i would
say this too
definitely and who would be an
inspiration for you as some sort of a
role model
elon musk although he's like super
super crazy and at some point but what i
like about him is like he's himself
um and he is not ashamed to be himself
um
um he doesn't have this image of like um
very confident you know what we have
always seen in entrepreneurs
very confident charismatic um
leader but he is uh more down to earth
and he has like a bit of weirdo views on
things
but at the same time uh he's the person
who can
dream big and envision something that
other people just can't see
and not just see but executed it so
anything that sounds
like a crazy for any human being on the
earth
is something possible for elon musk
that's
definitely
sorry about that and what are three
words that you would use to describe
yourself
um i would say um
passionate if i do something i'm really
like diving into that and sometimes too
much
and i need to pull myself out of that
and
kind of take a step back and reflect um
and i'm determined i i would say that
this is something that helped me to
still like despite of all the challenges
that i had
um to to keep on pushing
and yeah i would say that i'm a human
lover
so i just i just love human and and
i like to explore human and understand
them and
um connect with them and like i believe
that
if you are taking this journey of
entrepreneurship you will have to deal
with a lot of
um human resources and um
that's the best part of it because um
although this journey seems to be lonely
so you you do ha you don't have a lot of
time
to um to be social and
to go out and see your friends and
family that much
but when you are in the work you have
the team that you are
working with that's when like this
connection happens and you understand
that it's amazing how much
people can create when they manage to
kind of find
the mutual ground and find the mutual
vision and and just go for it so
everything seems to be possible then
amazing sabina thank you
very very much this was wonderful thank
you for taking the time and stay safe
and stay healthy and best of luck with
the launch
thank you thank you so much it was a
pleasure thank you have a nice day
michael
you